in the last few years a lot more machine
learning teams have been talking about
comparing the machine learning systems
to human level performance why is this I
think there are too many reasons first
is that because of advances in deep
learning machine learning algorithms are
suddenly working much better and so it's
become much more feasible a lot of
application areas from machine learning
algorithms to actually become
competitive with human level performance
second it turns out that the workflow of
designing and building machine learning
system the workflow is much more
efficient when you're trying to do
something that humans can also do so in
those settings it becomes natural to
talk about comparing or trying to mimic
human level performance let's see a
couple of examples of what this means
I've seen on a lot of machine learning
tasks that as you work on a problem over
time so the x-axis time this could be
many month or even many years over which
some team or some research community is
working on a problem progress tends to
be relatively rapid as you approach
human level performance but then after a
while the algorithm surpasses human
level performance and then progress and
accuracy actually slows down and maybe
keeps getting better but after
surpassing she'll of a performance you
can still get better at the performance
the slope of how rapidly axis is going
up often that slows down and the hope it
is achieves some theoretical optimum
level of performance and over time as
you keep training the algorithm may be
bigger and bigger models on more and
more data the performance approaches
that never surpasses some theoretical
limits which is called the deep phase
optimal error so Bayes optimal error
think of this as the best possible error
and that there's just no way for any
function mapping from X to Y to surpass
a certain level of accuracy so for
example for speech recognition if X is
audio clips some audio is just so noisy
is impossible to tell what is in the
correct transcription so the perfect
error may not be a hundred percent or
for cat recognition maybe some images
are so blurry that is just impossible
for anyone or anything to tell whether
or not does it count in that picture so
the perfect level of accuracy may not be
100% and Bayes also ever or Bayesian opt
for error or sometimes Bayes error for
short is the very best theoretical
function for mapping from X to Y that
can never be surpassed so it should be
no surprise that this Purple Line no
matter how many years you work on a
problem you can never surpass Bayes
error Bayes optimal error and it turns
out that progress is often quite fast
until you surpass human level
performance and it sometimes flows down
after you surpass human level
performance and I think there are two
reasons for that
for Y progress often slows down when you
surpass human level performance one
reason is that human level performance
is for many tasks not that far from
basil for error you know people are very
good at looking images and telling that
there's a cat or listening to audio and
transcribing it so by the time you
surpass human level performance maybe
there's not that much Headroom to still
improve but the second reason is that so
long as your performance is worse than
human level performance then there
actually certain tools you could use to
improve performance they're harder to
use once you've surpassed human level
performance so here's what I mean
patate that humans are quite good at and
this includes looking at pictures and
recognizing things listening to audio or
reading language really natural data
toss humans tend to be very good at
Fattah that humans are good at so long
as the machine learning is still worse
than the human you can get label data
from humans that is you can ask people a
higher humans to label examples for you
so you can have more data to feed your
learning algorithm something we'll talk
about next week is nano error analysis
but so long as humans are still
performing better than other learning
algorithm you can ask people to look at
example the your algorithm is giving
wrong and try to gain insight in terms
of why a person got it right but you
have got wrong and we'll see you next
week that this helps to improve your
outcomes and formats and you can also
get a better analysis of bias and
variance or talk about a little bit but
so long as your algorithm is still doing
worse than humans you have these
important tactics for improving your
algorithm whereas once your album is
doing better than humans then these
three tactics are harder to apply so
this is maybe another reason why
comparing to human level performance is
helpful especially on tasks that humans
do well and why machine learning
algorithms tend to be really good at
kinds of replicant tasks that people can
do and trying to catch up to and maybe
slightly surpass human level performance
in particular even though you know what
is bias and what is variance it turns
out that knowing how well humans can do
well on a task can help you understand
better how much you should try to reduce
bias and you should try to reduce
variance I want to show you an example
of this in the next video